the firecracker chili pepper is a
relatively easy plant to grow provided
you have the right conditions here are
some steps to help you get started
choose a location firecracker Chili
Peppers need plenty of sunlight so
choose a location that gets at least six
to eight hours of direct sunlight per
day they also prefer well-drained soil
with a fur between 6.2 and 7.0
start from seed you can start your
firecracker Chili Peppers from seed
indoors about six to eight weeks before
the last expected Frost or you can serve
them directly in the garden after all
danger a Frost has passed transplant
seedlings if you started your
firecracker Chili Peppers from seed
indoors transplant them outside once
they have at least two sets of true
leaves and the soil has warmed up to at
least 60 degrees Fahrenheit
space them about 18 to 24 inches apart
water regularly keep the soil moist but
not